-It's so nice to see you
in person.
Thank you so much
for doing our show
during Zoom, the shows --
you know, you're a friend
of the show.
I appreciate it. Thank you.
-Thanks for having me back.
Hi, everyone!
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ahh!
-Well, I want to talk
about your stand-up special.
Premiers tonight, HBO Max.
That's gigantic.
That's fantastic.
-Dream come true.
Dream come true. I'm so pumped.
-But you also have
a book of essays,
called "Please Don't Sit on My
Bed in Your Outside Clothes."
[ Laughter ]
Explain the title to me.
-[ Laughs ] Do you get it?
Questlove gets it.
So, you know, my parents
are very neat people.
They like a clean home.
And they're like,
"The outside world is triflin'.
Don't bring that in here."
So they would tell my brother
and I, just like,
change clothes --
put on your inside clothes.
Put on your pajamas or whatever.
And then that stuck with me, and
so then when I went to college,
went to Pratt Institute,
I wouldn't let anyone sit
on my bed in my dorm,
'cause I'm like, "You were
on the New York subway,
so you can't sit on there."
And then so many people
were like...
That was the one thing
people remembered about me,
so I was like, "Oh, my
personality was trash
in college."
[ Laughter ]
So... [ Laughs ]
-That's so...
-Yeah, it's horrible.
-I love that.
-Yeah.
-And do you still kind of
feel that way, or no?
-Yeah. Yes.
No, just please, just bring
an overnight bag.
Just bring a change --
Please don't sit on my stuff!
-I love that that's what they
remember about you, like of all
the funny things you're doing.
No, what's what you remember,
that I said...?
-Yeah.
-I love that.
I want to talk about
the stand-up special
because you shot this
in the middle of the pandemic,
at the botanical gardens?
-Yeah, in Brooklyn.
-In Brooklyn, which is you,
which I love.
-Yeah.
-What was it like?
-It was very exciting.
I was so nervous
'cause I was like,
I just hope we can get this off,
you know, with the delta.
The delta variant was like,
"Hey, Boo!"
And I was like...
I was like, "This is my moment!
Please!"
And we got through it.
-"Hey, Boo."
-Yeah. "Hey, Boo! I'm back!"
-[ Laughs ] No!
-I'm like, "No one invited you."
-Look at this spot.
-Look at those Peloton legs,
you guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at it!
Aah! Look at it!
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
But I love that you did it
and you go, "Yeah,
we're doing this safely
and we're putting this out there
'cause we need funny."
-Yes!
-We need content.
-We gotta just, like, relax
and laugh and not be
stressed out anymore.
So, I hope that people feel that
way when they watch the hour.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Phoebe Robinson
in "Sorry, Harriet Tubman."
Take a look at this.
-Now, don't get me wrong.
I love my boyfriend. I do.
He's my soul mate,
my best friend.
But during quarantine,
he was giving me major
"Do you have a moment to talk
about the environment?"
[ Laughter ]
You know those guys
on the street with vests,
holding clipboards,
just getting in your way?
[ Laughter ]
Asking you questions.
That was my boyfriend.
He was just trapping me
all over the apartment, okay?
He's like, "Are you hungry?
Want to order out?"
"Do you want to watch a movie
or play checkers?"
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, I'm just checking in.
I want to see how your day is."
And I was like, "Man, you have
an uncut, livestream feed
of how my day is going!"
[ Laughter ]
-You tell me! Exactly right.
Phoebe Robinson, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Sorry, Harriet Tubman"
is streaming right now
on HBO Max!
It's out! Congratulations!
-Whoo!